so last year you tied for entertainer of
the year you're nominated this year
what would it mean if you took home this
award again
uh it would it would mean the world you
know i mean even even just last year
um being nominated in that category that
was the first time i was ever nominated
for entertainer
and just as a kid you know as a 20 year
old kid that's what you dream about
you know you dream about hopefully you
recorded a bunch of great songs and
learned how to put on a really good show
and
had a lot of people come out to those
shows and have a blast and and you just
kind of hope that one day you might
your name might be in that bucket and uh
and for me it was last year and
you know getting getting to not only win
that but but tie that award with
somebody as iconic
as carrie you know i've known her for so
long always been such a giant fan
um it was just such a special feeling
you know especially with the year that
we had last year
um and then coming into this you know
i don't even know what my expectations
were you know um and then getting
nominated again for the second time in a
row was just uh
just a very humbling humbling feeling
and just just feel extra blessed about
it so
yeah i can only imagine now if you tie
with someone else this year
who are you who are you rooting for
oh my goodness uh man you know what i
think it would be so cool to watch luke
combs win this i
you know that to me there's there hasn't
been anyone that i saw like i got to see
luke's show last year which is one of
the
two years ago and just got to watch you
know 18 000 people just
not only sing singles and hits but just
screaming album cuts you know i haven't
seen that happen in so long with any
artist and uh
i just think it'd be really really
special for luke to take this one home
that's who i'm feeling for yeah that's a
good choice
um i'm loving your newest song country
again you said that this is one of your
favorite songs you've ever written
why is this one so special you know
every every few years i feel like i put
a song out that is just so
in the moment you know and the last one
was life changes you know and
and it always seems to be those songs
that you haven't written yet and you're
just like well we're going to call the
record something else and then you do
one more co-write and then
that song just pops out you know so we
had the majority of this record done and
and uh it was when i actually one of the
first zoom calls that i did for
co-writing and uh we wrote country again
and it just kind of slapped me across
the face it's like dude this is
it's what you've been doing you know
this is this is who you are today as a
31 year old dude and
and it just seems so fitting it just
became kind of the anchor for this whole
record
and uh you know i just every single line
in that song is as honest as it gets
you know i mean i learned that i was
living so fast-paced and the moment that
i
really decided to just slow down for a
second it just felt right you know and
it felt like a weight was lifted off my
shoulders and
and uh so i think there's a lot of
people in the world that can hear that
song and
and and relate it to their story as well
so it's definitely one of my favorites
i love that okay so what can you tease
us about your performance at the acm
awards this year yeah so we're actually
doing
just a little bit of a medley we're kind
of mixing two songs together so
um asim awards is gonna let me get up
there with a guitar uh
and a microphone and play a little bit
of country again uh and then mix it into
uh what's your country song so um
just a very it just feels like where i'm
at today and it's been real i've never
gotten to just sit down with a guitar at
an award show before and play
uh which is which is uh terrifying to me
as well because i got to play it right
um
but uh it's it's it's been a really cool
experience even just getting to rehearse
it you know so
um gonna be gonna be a special moment
now do you get
you know is there more pressure or do
you get even more nervous when you're
performing at a big awards show
or is this one just special because
you're up there with your guitar
i think it's both you know and for sure
over the last 10 years
um you know there's always a huge
audience to feed your
adrenaline and your and your nerves and
uh and so you know
last year there was hardly anybody in
the crowd except for cameras and this
year we have a bunch of um
amazing healthcare workers that are
going to sit in the crowd to get to
watch so
you want to do such a good job for them
that i would say that that's where the
nerves mostly come from
and also just knocking the rust off a
little bit you know everybody performing
tonight hasn't done this
in like a year and a half except for you
know to their computer screen
um and so a little bit of a learning
curve but um i just
it felt good to be nervous today you
know it felt good to have those
pre-show jitters uh something that i
didn't know how much i missed
oh i love that right right because you
know you want to stay away from being
nervous but
that reminds you what it's like to
perform again and it's nice to feel that
absolutely i mean i've never i've never
walked on stage and not been nervous you
know sometimes my band will look at me
and they'd be like you nervous and i'm
like yeah they're like okay good
you know you can take those nerves and
just transfer them into energy and
and there's there's just no better
feeling than that so oh i love that so
much now look
fans cannot wait for side a of your
double album to come out at the end
of the month there's so much music that
fans are going to get from you what did
you want to say with this whole project
i mean you know i think if you listen to
country again i think you're going to
get a very good vibe of what side a
and side b are going to feel like you
know somewhere around 2019 i just
really wanted to sit down and write with
people with just an acoustic guitar you
know i just wanted to start from scratch
and i wanted to
to figure out lyrics and really spend
time on these songs because it's the
first time i've
had in a very long time that i got to
just sit and and do that and really put
all my energy into making an album you
know
even my voice being getting getting to
be fresh for once you know going into
the vocal booth um
but i think it's you know i've loved all
my records that i've made but there's
just something a little bit
different about this one and i can't
pinpoint what it is i just feel like
anybody that i play the whole album for
top to down whether it's my friends or
family
you know even my wife the other day was
like i think this is your best album
that you've made and
so when you get to hear that from from
your wife who's heard a lot of really
bad songs in her day
um it's just a uh it's just a really
cool feeling and you know i think this
is just where i'm at as a as a person
and
uh this this record is what 31 sounds
like to me so
oh that's so exciting well speaking of
your family i have so much fun
looking at your kids and your wife on
your social media have your kids voiced
any interest in wanting to get into
music do they want to do what dad does
i don't think they care what i do just
yet you know um
i do they all love music like a lot um
you know there will be days where i'm
downstairs writing a song in the studio
and
um you know lennon my one-year-old will
literally just sit on my lap
and watch me and other people write
songs for like two hours you know
and willow grey and eda james are always
just in there just banging on the piano
or hitting drums or
you know knocking my guitars over and
and singing moana or frozen songs and
so they all have uh they all have really
good rhythm and and they all i think one
day will probably be able to
to do that if they felt like they wanted
to and that would be such an honor for
me just to get to show them
just the little knowledge that i have
and get to watch them kind of adapt into
who they want to be so
who knows uh you know they've already
shown an interest in love and music but
we'll see what the future holds
oh that's so exciting well to wrap
things up i can only imagine how busy
you are you
three kids you and lauren just must be
so busy have you talked at all about
wanting to expand your family i mean
yeah it's a conversation after every kid
you know um we got three now and three
is
complete chaos but we've learned to just
kind of dive into the chaos and
now when we even when me and lauren go
on date night or on you know vacation
just for three days just the two of us
we lay in bed and we're like man it's
really really quiet you know because
we've always got
three baby monitors sitting beside our
bed and there's rain sounds in their
bedroom and so when you get to lay there
for a second and get silent you're like
this is kind of weird you know and you
know lauren's always wanted a big family
and she then that that kind of mindset
has kind of rubbed off on me too like
she's always said she wanted five kids
and so
um we'll see i i don't know um we'll see
what happens i know we do want to grow
our family though
oh that's exciting i'm the oldest of
five kids i can tell you yeah
after three after three it doesn't
matter how many more you have it's
already kind of chaos but in like the
best yeah
abs that's what everybody says so yeah
oh well such an honor getting to talk to
you congratulations on all the
nominations can't wait to see what
happens
thank you so much good to talk to you
thank too
bye-bye